There is something maddening about a repetitive,
consistent sound, don’t you agree?
The narrator of Edgar Allen Poe’s The Tell-Tale
Heart is driven mad by the nonstop beating
of a heart coming from beneath his floorboards.
But even something less horrible than a disembodied
heartbeat can fray a person’s nerves.
Superficially less horrible, anyway.
Something as simple as, say, the relentless
ticking of a clock.
After all, what could be more frightening
than a reminder of the sands of time passing
through our fingers?
Of the finite steps on life’s long and winding
road?
We have the answer to that question: The scariest
thing of all is the monster waiting on the
other side of the road, twisted and hungry.
The thing that strikes when the ticking eventually
stops.
When time is up.
Tick.
Tock.
Many years ago, a clockmaker in the German
town of Freiburg was renowned for his ability
to produce exquisite personalized clocks for
his clientele all across the town, the country,
and even beyond.
His unparalleled constructions made him the
only man to reach out to when it came to getting
your hands on a beautiful, ornate timepiece
that would ease the anxieties of the passing
hours.
He ate, slept, and breathed clocks.
It was his life.
His calling.
As such, the clockmaker had grown accustomed
to the sound of ticking.
He heard it in the morning when he awoke to
the cry of his cuckoo clock, he listened to
it all day in his workshop as he repaired
and constructed clocks of all shapes and sizes,
and it was the sound that lulled him to sleep
at night after each long, hard day.
It gave life a pleasant rhythm.
One day, however, he noticed a particularly
loud, repetitive sound had permeated his home.
It was rhythmic, like the ticking of his clocks,
but harsher somehow.
It did not gently tick, but rather cracked,
like the way his knees popped when a harsh
winter was coming.
Something in it made his stomach ache with
dread.
He began taking apart every clock in his workshop,
looking for the source of the sound, but still,
it persisted.
He sat there at his desk, surrounded by gears
and pieces of wood, glass, and metal, and
still, the sound pounded against his eardrums.
Tick.
Tock.
The clockmaker was stumped by the mysterious
ticking noise.
It felt too real, too vivid, to be some kind
of hallucination.
He would have bet every clock he ever made
that the noise was coming from outside of
his head.
He was a man so astute in his clock-making
abilities that he could tell his own creations
apart in the dark from the mere timbre of
their ticking, but here, he was in the presence
of an alien force.
This frightening, almost predatory sound that
lingered in his periphery, always somewhere
but not confined to any fixed point.
He was reminded, vaguely, of Peter Pan.
Of the crocodile that’d eaten Captain Hook’s
hand and alarm clock, which survived and continued
ticking in the literal belly of the beast.
Hook, a vicious pirate captain, would become
a gibbering wreck when the ticking sound got
closer.
Did he fear the predator whom the ticking
foretold or the passage of time that pushed
him further into the reaper’s fold in the
otherwise immortal plane of Neverland?
Tick.
Tock.
The clockmaker’s search continued.
He turned his workplace upside down and inside
out in pursuit of the seemingly sourceless
ticking.
He checked in every hiding place, every closet,
cupboard, cubby hole, and cabinet.
Nothing.
He moved the furniture, tied up the curtains,
rolled up all the carpets.
Nothing.
In his desperation, he took a claw hammer
from his toolbox and began prying the rusty
nails from the ground, before peeling up the
floorboards and checking the dusty, spider-infested
spaces underneath.
Perhaps some mechanism had fallen down there,
or had always been there, just ticking away.
There had to be something down there.
But no.
Only dirt, insects, and shadows.
Maybe he was going mad.
Maybe it was tinnitus, or the indelible impression
that hearing years upon years of ticking had
left in his mind, the way an image is burned
into a plasma screen if it’s left there
for too long.
Maybe it was some shadowy government agency
trying to drive him mad with the use of some
new sound-based torture device.
Aural terrorism.
Selective auditory subliminal mind control.
Havana Syndrome.
The fizzling edges of sanity egged on by invisible,
long-range CIA telesound beams.
There had to be some kind of explanation.
But whatever the case, the sound persisted.
Tick, Tock, Tick, Tock…
He couldn’t stay there, in the dismembered
ruins of his prestigious clockmaking shop,
any longer.
He was clearly under a lot of stress here.
Not healthy.
Not good for the mind.
He decided to close the shop for a few days
and go visit his daughter and her family.
Some time with his beloved relatives would
soothe his frayed nerves.
So he packed his bag and made the trip, hoping
that leaving work behind for a few days would
also loosen up his mind.
But the entire drive to his daughter’s house,
he could have sworn he heard the sound still,
keeping perfect time as it cracked again and
again.
He shook his head, scolding himself for imagining
things.
There was nothing in the car that could be
making that noise.
He’d focused on it too much, surely, that’s
why he was obsessing over it now.
All of this had a rational explanation; he’d
simply thought himself into a corner on this
one.
Wouldn’t that explain all of this?
All just a trick in the mind of an overworked
clockmaker sorely in need of a good sabbatical
in the country.
This wouldn’t be forever.
Tick, Tock, Tick, Tock…
The clockmaker’s daughter greeted him at
the door with a warm embrace and a hearty
meal, and for a little while, he relaxed.
The sound of good company and laughter drowned
out the infernal ticking.
He began to entertain the notion that, perhaps,
the ticking had been a good thing.
It’d been a long time since he’d seen
his daughter, and that ticking, as frightening
as it had been, was also the only thing that
pushed him away from the workshop for a while.
He was somewhat grateful for a good excuse
to take time off.
Perhaps that was what all this was about.
A reminder to take it easy.
After a weekend off, he’d be right as rain,
surely?
But that night, as he tried to fall asleep,
the sound was there again.
Taunting him.
Keeping his eyes open wide and his heart rate
climbing.
Was it the dark of the room magnifying his
hearing, intensifying that awful ticking,
or was it louder and closer than ever before?
It felt as though an invisible clock, like
so many he’d made before, was hanging over
him.
But what was holding it?
That awful, awful sound.
Like the bubbles popping in the synovial fluids
of a person’s aged and crumbling joints.
Too organic.
Too fleshy.
And it just kept getting louder and closer,
louder and closer, louder and closer…
Tick…..Tock….Tick…Tock..Tick, TOCK,
TICK, TOCK, TICK, TOCK…
Until suddenly…it went silent.
He breathed a sigh of relief and closed his
eyes.
The clockmaker’s daughter woke to the sound
of her father’s piercing, guttural screams.
She ran to his room to find the bed sheets
soaked with blood, the bedroom window shattered,
and her father gone without a trace.
She went to the police the next day, but they
could do nothing for her.
Her father had not been the victim of an ordinary
murderer or thief, but something outside the
realm of understanding.
It was something ancient, something monstrous,
something…anomalous.
Though the police could do nothing, another
organization was secretly on the case: The
SCP Foundation.
After the clockmaker’s disappearance, operatives
searched the area and discovered the culprit,
which they captured and designated SCP-4975.
SCP-4975 is a humanoid entity with bird-like
features, the most notable of which is a sharp,
pointed beak.
Its body is long and thin, with bony limbs
with tapered points, with no discernible digits
of any kind.
Its body, including its beak, is covered with
a thick, hard layer of skin.
The entity’s most notable feature is not
its appearance, however, but in its skeleton,
particularly its spine.
The cervical vertebrae of the creature are
not interconnected, and are capable of independent
movement.
They rotate, one vertebra at a time, from
back to front in order, all the way up to
the entity’s head, in a particular rhythm.
This produces the clicking, or cracking sound
that is so terribly familiar to its intended
victims.
It repeats the motion constantly, over and
over again, only stopping when it is preparing
to attack its chosen prey.
SCP-4975 does not kill impulsively, simply
selecting a convenient victim.
Instead, it stalks its prey for months at
a time, sometimes even a year, following them
in darkness, hiding just out of sight.
The only sign of its presence is that sound,
the clicking, cracking, tick tock, tick tock
of its bones as it bides its time, knowing
that it can wait as long as it needs or wants
to before it strikes.
When it is ready to feast, it will beat and
tear at the victim’s body with the tapered
points of its limbs, shredding the flesh and
pecking at it much like a vulture rips at
a fresh carcass.
Then, it can savor its meal, using the body
as food for about three months before it needs
to hunt again.
Though its exact age is unknown, it is theorized
that the creature is hundreds, if not thousands,
of years old.
Written evidence of its existence has been
traced back as far as the 1500s.
There are mentions of a creature resembling
SCP-4975 throughout German folklore, appearing
in carvings, paintings, folk tales, and nursery
rhymes.
One such nursery rhyme was discovered and
translated by the Foundation during the research
process.
Though its rhyme scheme was lost when it was
translated to English, the eerie feeling it
evokes was not.
The rhyme goes:
“"Tick tock", the cuckoo clock ticks.
"Cuckoo", the bird inside sings.
Tick tock tick tock tick tock tick tock.
As ticks the time, so ticks your heart.
May you live long as you hear its song.
Tick tock tick tock tick tock tick tock.
Listen close, for when it stops
the hatchling comes out of its home.
Tick tock tick tock tick tock tick-
Did you hear it?
Did it stop?
My child, it meant your time was up.”
The research team theorizes that this nursery
rhyme, and others like it, was used to warn
children about potential indicators of danger
from SCP-4975, and teach them to be wary of
its hunting patterns.
Knowledge, after all, is one of the best weapons
in anyone’s arsenal when it comes to the
anomalous.
Without much more knowledge than this little
poem provides, and what they had observed
prior to SCP-4975’s capture, the SCP Foundation
did its best to create adequate containment
measures for the creature.
Currently, SCP-4975 is kept in a standard
steel containment cell, and is prohibited
from any direct human contact.
It can be observed via security footage, but
no human beings are permitted to go inside,
lest they serve as the creature’s next meal.
If a containment breach occurs, any personnel
that report hearing a repetitive cracking
or ticking sound are to be isolated until
the entity has been captured and placed back
in its cell, or until the sound stops.
Though SCP-4975 is currently contained, there
is a chance that it's captive state does not
actually make it any less lethal.
After a harrowing incident that sent many
attending researchers to the on-site psychologist’s
office, the Foundation was given reason to
believe that containing it does not actually
stop it from hunting.
On September 16, 2002, something horrible
happened near the Black Forest in Germany.
A team of Foundation operatives had been placed
in the area to monitor a man from Freiburg
who had complained to the local police about
a clicking sound that had been following him
around for quite some time.
Over the course of four months of being unable
to escape the sound, or the feeling that he
was being watched no matter where he went,
he had become convinced that someone was stalking
him.
It was a bizarre situation, and he wasn’t
certain how his stalker was making this maddening
sound, but he believed his life to be in danger.
Concerned that this could be the work of SCP-4975,
the Foundation operatives took him into their
custody.
The police were given a cover story, claiming
that the man was experiencing a sense of paranoia
as well as auditory hallucinations as a result
of side effects from chemotherapy.
Once the Foundation operatives explained to
the man that they meant him no harm, believed
him about his fears, and wished to help, he
opened up about his experiences.
He told the operatives that, in addition to
the sound and the feeling of something following
him, he had seen a monstrous figure in the
woods.
He had kept this detail to himself when speaking
to the police, afraid they would have him
committed rather than listening to him.
The operatives asked him to lead them to the
place where he had seen the monster, and he
agreed.
The man led the team to a densely wooded part
of the forest, trees blocking out the sunlight
until their surroundings became as dark as
if it were the middle of the night.
As they walked deeper and deeper into the
forest, the man became increasingly anxious.
His breath came in short, strained gasps,
his eyes darted from tree to tree, and he
jumped at the slightest sound of a twig snapping
beneath someone’s foot or branches rustling
in a gust of wind.
Suddenly, mid-stride, he froze.
His eyes were wide, his face white as a sheet.
With a trembling hand, he pointed toward a
nearby tree.
In a voice so faint it was almost a whisper,
he said: “There.”
The operatives turned to look, but saw nothing
there.
The man repeated, “There!”
but they couldn’t see anything but the trees.
The man stumbled back, going weak at the knees
from pure terror, and continued to point at
the empty space next to the tree.
Just as one operative was turning to another
to comment that their witness must be out
of his mind, the man suddenly collapsed onto
the ground, as if an invisible, powerful force
had thrown him down.
The man screamed for help, struggling against
the unseen attacker as it slashed at his face
and his chest, tearing through fabric and
skin, blood spraying across the forest floor.
Two officers drew their weapons, firing at
where they guessed the assailant might be,
but their bullets ricocheted uselessly off
of nearby tree trunks.
Another rushed to the man on the ground, grabbed
him under the arms, and attempted to pull
him out of harm’s way.
However, the man would not budge, as the invisible
force held him in place, shredding through
his stomach as it fought to keep its prey.
Afraid to rip open the stomach wound any further,
the operative quickly ceased his attempts
to move the man.
Instead, he pulled out his weapon and did
the only merciful thing he could think to
do: he shot the local man in the head, putting
him out of his misery before he was ripped
to shreds.
The operatives watched, some in silent shock,
some continuing to fire their weapons, some
vomiting from sheer disgust, as strips of
the dead man’s flesh ripped off the bone
and disappeared, one piece at a time.
Meanwhile, thousands of miles away, surveillance
footage at SCP-4975’s containment site picked
up some peculiar activity in the creature’s
cell.
It stopped rotating its neck, which it had
done almost constantly since being captured,
and stared at the corner of its containment
cell.
Its eyes were wide, unblinking, and it did
not move a muscle.
It stayed still for several minutes, until
it eventually broke the unsettling stillness
to eat, greedily gobbling down slices of meat.
There was one problem, though.
The creature had not yet been fed that day.
All Foundation operatives dispatched to Germany
to investigate SCP-4975 were recalled back
to their original sites, and additional research
has been suspended until further notice.
In light of this new information, a motion
has been filed to reclassify the creature
as Keter, and potentially impossible to contain
with the Foundation’s current resources.
As terrible as it is to admit, this is one
monster the Foundation has not yet found a
way to stop.
They may have it locked in a cage, but it
can still hunt anyone, anywhere, any time
it wants to.
Wait a second.
Shh, be very quiet.
What’s that sound?
In your room, right now.
Listen closely.
Tick.
Do you hear it?
Don’t worry, it’s probably just a clock
or a kitchen timer.
Maybe it’s just your imagination.
Tick.
Whatever it is, I’m sure you’ll be fine.
There’s nothing dangerous about a weird
sound from time to time.
You don’t have anything to fear unless it
suddenly goes silent.
That’s when you’re really in trouble,
when you know what SCP-4975 is about to strike,
to devour you alive.
Wait.
Stop.
Hold your breath, don’t make a single peep.
Do you hear it?
Neither do I.
Now go check out “SCP-2316 - The Bodies
in the Water” and “SCP-966 - Sleep Killer”
for more haunting anomalies of the SCP Foundation.